u.s president joe biden is in buffalo
new york where a gunman shot dead ten
people just days ago
police are investigating the attack as a
racist hate crime the president and
first lady are meeting with family
members of those killed as well as
community leaders the alleged gunman is
an 18 year old who has shown support for
white supremacist ideals he attacked a
grocery store in a predominantly african
american neighborhood and 11 of the 13
people hit with gunfire were black
president biden spoke just a while ago
calling white supremacy theories a
poison and asking americans to speak out
against such ideas
in america evil will not win i promise
you
hate will not prevail
and white supremacy
will not have the last word
what happened here is simple and
straightforward terrorism
terrorism domestic terrorists
well now washington bureau chief ines
poll is in buffalo she spoke of her
president clearly moved by the
consequences of this shooting
i actually only saw two presidents
tearing up while they were delivering a
speech one was president obama
while talking after the school shooting
of sandy hook and today
president biden when he was talking
about a victim who just wanted to buy a
birthday cake
for his son and got killed so this was
on the one side a very very emotional
speech when he talked about each single
victim with very personal
remarks and then it was also very strong
political message he said that evil was
in buffalo and it was white supremacy
which killed here in
buffalo he recognized the shooter as a
terrorist who followed a racist
conspiracy theory and he called it
directly domestic terrorism
is there anything more you can tell us
about the suspect
the suspect came from 200 miles away or
so why because this is a very black
neighborhood of buffalo so he came here
to this very supermarket right behind me
because he could be pretty sure that he
mainly would be able to kill black
americans we know that he when he was 17
right before he graduated already talked
about
a mass shooting and then he got some
treatment by psychologists but got out
of the hospital again and then once he
graduated kind of fell off the radar of
uh police
we know that he got his first weapon
from his father with when he was 16 we
know that he loved weapons and we know
that he was kind of a loner
and what about this white supremacist
replacement theory that
he's been uh talking about
there's also something uh president
biden referred to in his speech
recalling the white supremacists the
neo-nazis
marching into charlottesville virginia
shouting
we will replace you and with you
they mean non-white americans and that
was the very moment when president biden
decided to run again also to fight
this ideolo ideology which was actually
founded by a
frenchman
some 10 years ago
mainly kind of saying that only white
christians have the right kind of to
live here and everybody else should be
excluded and this is highly political
here in this country why because
republicans use that argument to say
that democrats led for example
immigrants into the country just only
for the reason that they would get
reelected so all in all a very hateful
and a very political ideology
dw's bureau chief in the u.s in s poll
thank you very much for your coverage